vsauce kevin here and this penny brick
contains a strictly monotonically
increasing sequence to detect
fraud that depends in part on an
eight-year-old genius in the 1700s and
how loaded with useless knowledge your
brain is
it also contains 50 rolls of 50 american
pennies
each of which weighs two and a half
grams and is composed of 97.5
zinc and 2.5 copper
here's the problem one of these 50 rolls
is full of fakes
which one of you is looking
a little suss
vicious the fake one could be
anywhere the only thing i know is that
the counterfeit pennies
are half a gram lighter than real
pennies
that's too light though to feel out by
hand so
i've got to measure them how i could
measure all
50 rolls one by one until i found the
fakes
every roll should be 125 grams for the
pennies plus 3 grams
for the wrapper it'll work but it could
take up to 50 measurements
the weird thing is there's actually an
elegant way to measure just
once take one single measurement to find
out
exactly which stack is phony
that solution is not obvious so let's
start
with the obvious you know you can speed
up measuring by
say breaking the 50 stacks into five
groups
of ten measure the five groups and one
will be light measure the ten stacks in
that group until you find the fake
if you're super lucky twenty percent
chance you get the right group on the
first try
ten percent chance it's the right stack
there's a
two percent chance you could do this in
just
two measurements but it could take
15. there's a 100 chance it'll work and
you know that because it's in your
system one
you've stored so many patterns and
processes in the dual process
model of your brain system one
thinking is the automatic intuition you
build up
with knowledge and experience it's what
your brain knows
before you even know you know system two
is the slower calculated thought you
apply it with
here's a question which system do you
need to measure
50 stacks of pennies just once
and be guaranteed to find the imposter
both you need both first i gotta find
out what 50 stacks of pennies
should weigh 2.5 grams times 50 squared
equals 6250 grams
or 6.25 kilograms if fake pennies are
half a gram
short a stack of 50 will be 25 grams too
light cool
now what now you need to know patterns
you need to know
sequences maybe you got it from studying
convergent and divergent series maybe it
was
euler maybe it was calculus maybe it was
projected
investment growth or growing student
loan debt but
somehow the long arrangement of numbers
and the
implications of those sequences and
series need to be
somewhere in your system one like one
plus two plus three plus four plus five
plus six
plus it's infinite and with the
ramanujan summation
that adds up to negative one over twelve
but
that's another video not this one and
we're not adding infinitely we're only
going to
50. and that summation is so simple that
even an eight-year-old can do it because
literally an eight-year-old carl gauss
discovered
the method carl gauss is one of
history's greatest mathematicians and
as a child he realized that any series
of adding consecutive numbers could be
done
by taking the whole set of numbers and
dividing it by
two then multiplying that result by the
first plus the last
number so one through fifty fifty
divided by two
times one plus fifty or twenty five
times fifty one equals
one thousand 1275 thanks eight-year-old
carl when i was eight years old i was
listening to nirvana's never mind on
cassette
and begging my mom for a sega genesis
anyway
if we treat the 50 stacks as potential
consecutive numbers and take one penny
from the first stack
two pennies from the second stack three
pennies from the third stack
and so on all the way to the 50th stack
our consecutive penny stack series will
give us
total pennies at two and a half grams
each minus the wrappers that's three
thousand
one hundred eighty seven and a half
grams when we take
one single weight measurement of our
divergent series inspired gaussian child
genius pennies it will be short by a
certain number of grams we'll know
exactly how many pennies of the 1275
are fakes because if it's short seven
grams
14 fake pennies 19 grams 38
fakes and since we took the number of
pennies corresponding to the number of
stacks like
taking 13 pennies from stack number
13 however many fake pennies we have in
the group
actually tell us which stack the fakes
came out of
so let's find out which of my stacks
is the fake
oh
none none none of these pennies
are actually fake i got them i got them
from the bank i just
i really wanted to visualize this
problem because
it changed my mind about how thinking
functions we we just
do not do this stuff every day to
stumble on the right process here you
probably had to have done some real
thought about
consecutive numbers and number series in
the past if
if that's not in your system one then
system two doesn't have
a lot to work with you could just
i guess sort of figure it out if you'd
never worked with a number series before
if your name is carl gauss the
the rest of us need to know things a lot
of things and
there's no guarantee that what's in your
system one will ever be useful
because it just isn't
until it is will you need to know
specifically how to reveal a roll of
counterfeit coins in a single
measurement probably not
but what problem will you need to solve
using the number patterns mathematical
processes and
even real answers that you've acquired
over a lifetime
without a system one loaded with math
and science archimedes gets in the
bathtub
sees the displacement of water
correlating with his body and
i don't know washes his smelly armpits
there would have been nothing for system
2
to activate there's no way to know
how you'll put information and patterns
and relationships and knowledge together
to solve a very real problem
in your future but the more
information you pack into your system 1
the more likely it is that your system 2
will get the job done and as always
i have so many pennies to roll
thanks for watching
[Music]
you